I'm an astronomer who builds telescopes
I build telescopes because number one
they are awesome but number two I
believe if you want to discover a new
thing about the universe you have to
look at the universe in a new way new
technologies and astronomy things like
lenses photographic plates all the way
up to space telescopes each gave us new
ways to see the universe and directly
lead to a new understanding of our place
in it but those discoveries come with a
cost it took thousands of people and 44
years to get the Hubble Space Telescope
from an idea into orbit it takes time it
takes a tolerance for failure
it takes individual people choosing
every day not to give up I know how hard
that choice is because I live it the
reality of my job is that I fail almost
all the time and still keep going
because that's how telescopes get built
the telescope I helped build is called a
faint intergalactic medium redshifted
emission balloon which is a mouthful so
we call it fireball and don't worry it
is not going to explode at the end of
this story I've been working on fireball
for more than 10 years and now lead the
team of incredible people who built it
fireball is designed to observe some of
the faintest structures known huge
clouds of hydrogen gas these clouds are
giant they are even bigger than whatever
you're thinking of they are huge huge
clouds of hydrogen that we think flow
into and out of galaxies I work on
fireball because what I really want is
to take our view of the universe from
one with just light from stars to one
where we can see and measure every atom
that exists that's all that I want to do
but observing at least some of those
atoms is crucial to our understanding of
why galaxies look the way they do I want
to know how that hydrogen gas gets into
a galaxy and creates a star my work on
fireball started in 2008 working not on
the telescope but on the light sensor
which is the heart of any telescope this
new sensor was being developed by a team
that I joined at NASA's Jet Propulsion
Laboratory and our goal was to prove
that this sensor would work really well
to detect that hydrogen gas in my work
on this I destroyed several very very
very expensive sensors before realizing
that the machine I was using created a
plasma that shorted out anything
electrical that we put in it we used a
different machine there were other
challenges and it took years to get it
right but when that first sensor worked
it was glorious and our sensors are now
10 times better than the previous state
of the art and are getting put into all
kinds of new telescopes our sensors will
give us a new way to see the universe
and our place in it so sensors done time
to build a telescope and fireball is
weird
as far as telescopes go because it's not
in space and it's not on the ground
instead it hangs on a cable from a giant
balloon and observes for one night only
from 130,000 feet in the stratosphere at
the very edge of space this is partly
because the edge of space is much
cheaper than actual space so building it
of course more failures mirrors that
fails scratch mirrors that had to be
remade cooling system failures an entire
system that had to be remade calibration
failures we ran tests again and again
and again and again failures when you
literally least expect them
we had an adorable but super angry baby
falcon that landed on our spectrograph
tank one day although to be fair this
was the greatest day in the history of
this project
I really love that Falcon but Falcon
damage fix we got it built for an August
2017 launch attempt and then failed to
launch due to six weeks of continuous
rain in the New Mexico desert our
spirits dampened we showed up again
August 2018 year ten and on the morning
of September 22nd we finally got the
telescope launched I have put so much of
myself my whole life into this project
and I like still can't believe that that
happened and I have this picture that's
taken right around sunset on that day of
our balloon fireball hanging from it and
the nearly full moon and I love this
picture I love it but I look at it and
it makes me want to cry because when
fully inflated these balloons are
spherical and this one isn't it's shaped
like a teardrop and that's because
there's a hole in it sometimes balloons
fail to fireball crash-landed in the New
Mexico desert and we didn't get the data
that we wanted and at the end of that
day I thought to myself why am I doing
this and I've thought a lot about why
since that day and I've realized that
all of my work has been full of things
that break and fail that we don't
understand and they fail that we just
get wrong the first time
and so they fail I think about the
thousands of people who built Hubble and
how many failures they endured there
were countless failures heartbreaking
failures even when it was in space and
none of those failures were a reason for
them to give up I think about why I love
my job I want to know what is happening
in the universe you all want to know
what's happening in the universe - I
want to know what's going on with that
hydrogen
and so I've realized that discovery is
mostly a process of finding things that
don't work and failure is inevitable
when you're pushing the limits of
knowledge and that's what I want to do
so I'm choosing to keep going and our
team is gonna do what everyone who has
ever built anything before us has done
we're gonna try again
in 2020 and it might feel like a failure
today and it really does but it's only
gonna stay a failure if I give up thank
you very much
[Applause]